deux clowns sur le banc toile pas
renverser la famille
[Musique]
effectivement le mali plancher wsc rien
at il dit ma profession je m'en vais la
suivre à la télé est double poster blacy
porte vélos de ville et aussi causé la
démence est projetée pourrait l'attendre
ans et ça fait maintenant un mois
qu'elle n'eut au chant à ta vie dans la
rue alors droite polybel annick je me
suis blessé je pile le bouchon et 2 je
mets un tig la zoé doit je vais te la
moisson des caches veulent à ce niveau
etc
c
la serbie est la gym tonic quand il faut
semer c'est plutôt bien
en une journée blanche où le blanc mais
c'est pour les riches les pauvres est
forte à leurs cadres être la malicieuse
challans qu'elles font plus aimé du
brand pour s'en saisit tout lui est bon
et cette année pour les moissons
pas la peine donc j'ai des hommes pour
vaja jeter un métronome et pour les
soutenir moralement je m'en restait 20
ans démarré jeudi le bouchon qe2 je mets
un petit glaçons et droit je vais je le
vois son des canons
la paire vie
robic
la paire robin
on y est
les jolies gesticule elle est remonté
comme une pendule one
c'est plus tard sans nourrir les vaches
et les cochons à 34 euros
mais ces colis sabrina veut et bien
direction du bloc bleu et c'est vrai
les sports mais qu'on sera dans notre
show télé c'est toute l'équipe et je
viens y auraient droit
je vais je le vois jouer ceux-ci vont
baisser
là
et
robbie alléger ma voile tennis c'est
ça
m
[Musique]